Traductor: Daniela Pardo
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
En la primavera de 1944,
los ciudadanos de Tokio
sufrieron varios ataques aéreos
por parte de las tropas Aliadas.
El sonido de las sirenas los alertaba
para que se refugiaran
y precedían apagones estratégicos
a lo largo de la ciudad.
Pero Hisako Koyama, de 28 años,
veía esos apagones como oportunidades.
Levando un futón en su cabeza
como protección,
Koyama contemplaba el cielo nocturno,
buscando todo tipo
de fenómenos astronómicos.
Sin embargo, para su último intento
necesitaba la luz del día.
Al apuntar su telescopio hacia el sol,
Koyama podía plasmar la luz
de las estrellas en una hoja de papel,
lo que le permitía hacer un boceto
de la superficie cambiante del sol.
Pasó semanas recreando este método,
registrando cada cambio que observaba.
Pero aunque Koyama no lo supiera,
estos diseños eran el comienzo
de uno de los registros más importantes
de la actividad solar
en la historia de la humanidad.
Para entender por completo
qué vio Koyama en la superficie del sol,
primero necesitamos entender
lo que sucede dentro de la estrella.
Cada segundo,
billones de moléculas de oxígeno
se fusionan con moléculas de helio
en un proceso llamado: fusión nuclear.
Esta explosión continua
mantiene la temperatura interna del sol
de 15 millones de grados centígrados,
aproximadamente,
lo que es más que suficiente energía
para transformar gas
en agitados charcos de plasma.
El plasma consiste de partículas cargadas
que generan poderosos campos magnéticos.
Pero a diferencia de las partículas
cargadas y estables
que mantienen
la actividad magnética de la Tierra,
este plasma está en constante movimiento,
alterando y aumentando
el campo magnético del sol.
Este movimiento continuo puede generar
concentraciones temporales
de actividad magnética
que inhiben el movimiento de las moléculas
y terminan reduciendo el calor en el área.
Y ya que las zonas con menos calor
generan menos luz,
los lugares con campos magnéticos
más fuertes aparecen como manchas oscuras
esparcidas en la superficie del sol.
Estas “manchas solares”
están siempre en movimiento,
como resultado del plasma
que se mueve dentro de la esfera
y de la rotación del sol.
Y ya que suelen aglomerarse,
contar y rastrear el movimiento
de las manchas puede ser todo un desafío,
que depende, en gran medida,
de la percepción y juicio del observador.
Esto es justamente lo valioso
de las contribuciones de Koyama.
A pesar de no tener
una formación en astronomía,
sus observaciones y bocetos
fueron asombrosamente precisos.
Después de enviar su trabajo
a la Asociación Astronómica Oriental,
recibió una carta de reconocimiento
por sus detalladas observaciones.
Con este apoyo, comenzó a visitar
el Museo de Ciencia de Tokio
donde pudo usar un mejor telescopio
para continuar con su trabajo.
Koyama pronto formó parte del personal
del museo como observadora profesional,
y durante los siguientes 40 años
trabajó todos los días
en más de 10 000 bocetos
de la superficie solar.
Los investigadores ya sabían
que las corrientes magnéticas del sol
seguían un ciclo de 11 años,
en el que las manchas solares
seguían un camino con forma de mariposa.
Pero al usar el registro de Koyama,
pudieron seguir con precisión
manchas y grupos específicos
en ese recorrido.
Este nivel de detalle ofreció
una indicación, en tiempo real,
de la actividad magnética solar,
lo que permitió a científicos rastrear
todo tipo de fenómenos solares,
incluyendo las volátiles
erupciones solares.
Estas erupciones suelen emanar
de los alrededores de las manchas solares,
y pueden llegar
hasta la atmósfera de la Tierra.
Aquí, pueden crear tormentas geomagnéticas
capaces de interrumpir comunicaciones
de larga distancia y de provocar apagones.
Las erupciones solares son un riesgo
para satélites y estaciones espaciales,
lo que hace imprescindible
poder predecirlas y rastrearlas.
En una entrevista en 1964,
Koyama lamentó que sus 17 años
de observación fueron apenas suficientes
para crear un solo registro
del ciclo solar en forma de mariposa.
Pero al final de su carrera, había creado
bocetos de tres ciclos y medio.
Uno de los mayores registros
de la historia.
Mejor aún, la calidad de sus bocetos
eran tan consistente
que los usaron como referencia
para reconstruir los últimos 400 años
de la actividad de las manchas solares
desde varias fuentes históricas.
Este proyecto extendió el legado de Koyama
más allá de su vida,
y demuestra que la ciencia no solo se crea
con increíbles descubrimientos,
sino que también con una observación
meticulosa del mundo que nos rodea.